parce que voilà
il est un peu susceptible donc à l'issue
des auditions nos deux rapporteurs
vivaient Lopez en présentiel et est à
Nîmes Olivier qui a peut-être des
difficultés pour se connecter à distance
feront des propositions que nous
examinerons en réunion plénière je le
dis pour les membres qui sont présents
et qui nous écoutent le mercredi 28 juin
à 13h30
notre réunion sera suivie d'une
conférence de presse le même jour à
16h30 après les questions d'actualité au
gouvernement comme vous le savez notre
délégation c'est depuis longtemps saisi
la problématique foncière qui est
absolument cruciale en outre-mer et a
consacré trois rapports ils ont été
coordonnés par notre collègue tany
Mohamed solidim dont nous saluons
l'engagement et la détermination à
traiter ces sujets
les conflits d'usage sont
particulièrement menaçants pour le Foss
agricole le grignotage des surfaces
agricoles utiles est un phénomène qui
nous inquiète tous la Guyane ou la forêt
équatoriale représente 90% du territoire
fait figure d'exception mais ça a eu la
surface à l'école utile ne constitue que
0,4 % de la surface totale nous nous
interrogeons sur les instruments de
protection et de reconquête des terres
agricoles à mobiliser notamment pour
tendre vers souveraineté alimentaire
évidemment objectif que nous partageons
de ce ministre permettez-moi d'insister
chers collègues sur le contexte de cette
audition nous sommes à quelques jours de
comité interministériel pour les
outre-mer le siome attendu comme le
messie d'ailleurs nous comptons sur des
mesures fortes bien évidemment afin de
protéger ce patrimoine agricole qui est
la base même je dirais même le substrat
de l'autre autonomie dans ce domaine à
l'horizon 2030 nous savons également
qu'une grande loi d'orientation et
d'avenir agricole est en préparation et
que des consultations sont en cours dans
les outre-mer pour faire remonter les
difficultés et les suggestions nous
souhaitons apporter notre contribution à
ce texte bien évidemment qui sera sans
doute soumis au Parlement à l'automne
nous espérons mais c'est le ministre que
vous pourrez nous en dire davantage des
arbitrages interviendront prochainement
aussi pour la prochaine loi de finances
et nous vous donnons rendez-vous lors de
la prochaine discussion budgétaire pour
concrétiser les annonces en faveur du
monde agricole avec nos rapporteurs nous
félicitons donc tout particulièrement de
l'échange d'aujourd'hui nous souhaitons
vous entendre dans votre propos
liminaire sur vos actions en faveur de
la préservation et du développement du
foncier école du tramarin sur la base de
la trame monsieur le ministre qui vous a
été transmise par vos services et nous
engagerons ensuite à discussion avec les
rapporteurs et les collègues qui
participent à cette audition monsieur le
ministre je vous laisse la parole
merci beaucoup monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Président Mesdames madame et
messieurs et monsieur le rapporteur
mesdames et messieurs les membres de la
délégation outre-mer d'abord merci de
m'accueillir au sein de votre délégation
c'est la première fois que j'ai
l'occasion de le faire dans les
fonctions du ministre de l'agriculture
et de la souveraineté alimentaire et
donc je suis très heureux de pouvoir
être devant vous pour cette audition je
sais d'ailleurs
que la question du foncier dans les
outre-mer est un sujet qui préoccupe de
longue date votre délégation et je
partageais évidemment avec vous
l'importance de ce sujet notamment
regardez l'acuité des enjeux de
souveraineté c'est bien là qu'il faut
faire un lien me semble-t-il dans ces
territoires la question du foncier de sa
disponibilité bien le préalable à cette
question agricole en particulier dans
ces territoires qu'il s'agisse du
renouvellement des générations des choix
culturels ou encore d'adaptation et de
lutte contre le changement climatique
les territoires ultramarins de ce point
de vue
sont particulièrement sensibles avec un
foncier limité pour les territoires
insulaires une géographie et une
météorologique qui contraignent par
ailleurs les mises en culture plusieurs
en ont pour le foncier agricole dans les
territoires ultramarins à fortiori
lorsqu'ils sont insulaires limiter
l'artificialisation
contenir l'emprichissement mobiliser
tout le foncier agricole disponible pour
bâtir une souveraineté alimentaire
durable je dirais assez volontiers dans
cette erreur une sécurité alimentaire
durable j'aimerais partager donc avec
vous quelques éléments avant qu'on nous
puissions échanger comme vous le savez
le président de la République avait
initié en octobre 2019 une démarche de
transformation agricole des outre-mer et
puis en l'objectif de temps vers la
souveraineté alimentée en 2030 en éligi
en terminale a été nommé pour coordonner
la démarche plusieurs comités de
transformation se sont tenus dans chacun
des territoires et j'ai moi-même écrit
en janvier 2023 MV avec mes collègues du
gouvernement chargé des Outre-mer de la
santé au préfet et de la mer au préfet
pour leur demander de produire une
feuille de route territoriale
vers la souveraineté alimentaire ces
feuilles de route ont désormais tout été
établies en concertation avec l'ensemble
des acteurs locaux des indicateurs ont
été produits et des signes ont été
définis nous maintenant construire de
nouveaux équilibres pour permettre de
renforcer l'autonomie la souveraineté la
sécurité alimentaire de ces territoires
on l'a vu d'ailleurs dans la crise
ukrainienne dans la crise covid à quel
point ces territoires étaient sensibles
aux dérèglement ou dysfonctionnement
qu'on peut connaître aujourd'hui les
taux de couverture sont accessibles en
ligne sur le site de l'odeada mais les
cibles seront publiés sur l'outil pilote
pour vous donner quelques informations
concernant l'évolution de la surface
agricole utile l'accessible grâce aux
résultats des recensments généros
agricoles on observe dans les dromes
comme dans l'Hexagone un recul continu
depuis 98 88 pardon la Guyane faillite
exception
puisque c'est le seul territoire où la
sciu progresse depuis cette date en
conséquence des actions de protection du
foncier sont engagées dans chacun de ces
territoires en Guadeloupe Martinique et
à la Réunion une safer dispose d'un
droit de préhension pour maîtriser le
marché foncier agricole et assurer sa
destination agricole vers l'installation
d'agriculteurs le maintien ou la
consolidation d'exploitation à Mayotte
le droit de prévention agricole est
exercée par l'établissement public
foncier en Guyane après des difficultés
que pour certains d'entre vous
connaissent une safer est en cours de
constitution et des travaux doivent
conduire à la mise en oeuvre des
transferts de fonciers au bénéfice des
collectivités des communautés
d'habitants et de la SAFER précité tels
que prévu par les accords de Guyane de
2017 ces travaux portent notamment sur
l'identification des zones
susceptibles d'être transféré dans tous
ces territoires la cdp9 doit émettre un
avis conforme justement pour tenir
compte de l'importante pression foncière
qui si exerce dans l'Hexagone et sa
faire trouve à leur équilibré
à raison de l'importance du marché des
transactions foncières agricoles sur
lequel se rémunère la situation
reconnaissons-le est très différente
dans les outre-mer ou le marché est
beaucoup moins important le gouvernement
accompagne donc les affaires
ultramarines en Guyane une aide a été
attribuée au Gyps à faire lors de sa
constitution et il est prévu une aide
supplémentaire à la SAFER qui vient
délire sa présidente pour l'accompagner
dans son installation la production de
son programme pluriannuel d'activité
de la SAFER dit PPAS sur un acte
important dans ce territoire à la
différence des établissements publics
fonciers je rappelle que les affaires
sont des sociétés anonymes relevant du
droit privé si cela leur donne une
gouvernance plus proche des acteurs
économiques locaux cela a également pour
conséquent une justification bien plus
ardue de l'octroi de subvention publique
encadrée par le droit européen ou
d'affectation d'une taxe à leur profit
je rappelle en outre que le code rural
et de la pêche prévoit un fond de
l'équation dans l'ensemble des affaires
qui peut permettre des structures
ultramarines
il revient au safer et leur fédération
nationale il me semble que c'est
d'ailleurs un sujet pour être très
transpar à vous de ces saisir de cet
outil ce qui n'est à date pas le cas en
dehors de ces considérations une voyance
affaire d'identifier localement leurs
axes de travail dans les programmes
pluriels d'action stratégiques le
développement des prestations de service
d'aménagement et de réalisation d'études
sont des pistes de développement
permettant d'augmenter les recettes de
ces sociétés autre outil de régulation
du foncier je vous l'ai dit les cdp9
comme mission départementale de
préservation des espaces naturels
agricoles et forestiers qui dispose dans
les territoires du maintien
ultramarins du maintien d'un avis
conforme contrairement à l'Hexagone pour
permettre une bonne prise en compte des
caractéristiques de ces territoires
insularité frontières des pays de
l'Union européenne dans un but de
protection du foncier agricole c'est un
sujet de débat assez récurrent entre la
profession colle mais je ne doute pas
que vous m'interrogerez
sur la pertinence ou non l'efficience ou
non de cet outil suite à une demande
d'adaptation formulée par les maires par
les maires de ces territoires au
président de la République en février
2019 la loi a été modifiée pour que cet
avis conforme ne s'applique pas pour les
projets comportant en majorité des
logements sociaux
on remonte mais c'est peut-être pas ce
que vous me direz donc je verrai qu'il y
a peu il y a assez peu de difficultés
dans le fonctionnement actuel des cdp9
ou tous les acteurs sont représentés
au-delà d'un sujet de postulat de base
j'ajoute sur ces sujets fonciers ce que
c'est important il y a la question de
l'adaptation au changement climatique et
notamment la question de la gestion de
l'eau qui est un élément important la
sobriété travaille sur la disponibilité
de la ressource sont indissociables et
font partie des leviers essentiels
inclus dans le varen agricole de l'eau
et de l'adaptation aussi je m'en
climatique pourquoi je fais le lien
parce que c'est un élément qui permet de
valoriser une mobiliser à destination
agricole du foncier qu'on a besoin d'y
travailler il me semble que c'est
important de le dire je ne reviens pas
il y aura peut-être des questions sur
les plantes souveraineté divers et les
feuilles de route c'était des questions
qui étaient posées façon connexe mais
j'y reviendrai il me semble qu'on a
besoin aussi de travailler sur la
question parce que c'est le poids de
l'histoire des des indivisions qui
explique une partie des difficultés
relatives aux fonciers dans les
outre-mer une des dispositions de la loi
d'avenir de 2014 visite à faciliter la
sortie de la vision notamment lorsque
l'accord de tous les individuels ne
pouvait être obtenu en ce qui concerne
l'application de la loi les chimie de
2018 visant à favoriser la sortie des
indivisions je sais que les travaux ont
été conduits par le Parlement et je suis
prêt examiné les propositions qui en
découleraient vous évoquez dans votre
questionnaire la question des friches
agricoles les aides du posé ont pour
objectif de soutenir la couverture des
besoins des populations par des
productions locales c'est pour cette
raison que les aides sont couplées aux
quantités produites et commercialisées
dans ce contexte une aide surfacique
découplée comme il en existe dans
l'Hexagone n'apparaît pas comme étant le
dispositif le plus adapté à la situation
spécifique des territoires ultramarins
et du fait notamment de leur taille et
de leur éloignement en effet une lettre
découplée décorrélée de la production et
donc sa mise en oeuvre ne garantit pas
une augmentation des volumes produits à
l'inverse des aides couplées or c'est
bien l'objectif que nous avons dans ces
territoires cela a été un choix
politique assumé au moment de la mise en
place des aides posées au même ou même
du somme de 2009
des réserves foncières existent la
problématique des terres est réel
on les doit trouver aussi des solutions
dans la concertation locale il existe
pour cela les instances d'aménagement
fonciers pour la valorisation des terres
inclutes auxquelles il est trop peu fait
appel sans doute à date j'aurais terminé
en évoquant avec vous les questions
d'installation de transmission et de
renouvellement des générations vous le
savez j'ai lancé vous l'avez dit
monsieur le Président de consultation
préalable à la définition d'impact et du
noir c'est bien les deux objets quand il
faut pouvoir se saisir j'ai souhaité
cette constipation vous l'avoue aussi
indiqué soit territorialisée c'est ce
qui a été le cas aussi dans les
outre-mer plusieurs propositions
émergent des consultations menées dans
ces territoires sur les thèmes de
l'orientation et de la formation
l'installation et de la transmission et
de l'adaptation transition face au
changement climatique certaines
propositions sont communes à l'Hexagone
comme le promotion auprès des plus
jeunes des problématiques ou des sujets
agricoles et alimentaires la création de
points d'accueil
unique ou de guichet unique installation
transmission encore le besoin
d'accompagnement technique renforcé face
au changement climatique d'autres
reflètent plutôt les spécificités
ultramarines comme l'enseignement dans
les langues locales l'homologation des
intrants adaptés aux conditions
tropicales ou la question des desserts
agricoles je pense en particulier au
territoire guyanais toutes ces
propositions sont en train d'être
examinées d'être compilées si vous
permettez cette expression afin de
projet de pouvoir présenter un texte au
cours du deuxième semestre de l'année
comme c'est prévu à date la question des
retraites agricoles est évidemment liée
à la question de la transmission on sait
que c'est un sujet qui a été évoqué lors
d'ailleurs lors de la visite de la
première ministre à la Réunion et donc
on a besoin aussi de travailler pour
libérer du foncé il y en a un question
de retraite pour des gens qui ont des
retraites qui sont trop faibles dans ces
territoires en particulier le dispositif
de pré-retraite figuré dans les
programmes de développement ruraux
régionaux dont la gestion comme ça vous
le savez n'est plus désormais de la
responsabilité de l'État en ce qui
concerne la location de solidarité aux
personnes âgées je sais que ce sujet
concerne aussi je suis pour un parfum
favorable à ce que les particularités
ultramarines qui permettraient je dis de
libérer du foncé puisse être examiné
l'histoire est différente notamment le
phénomène des corps de ferme où l'on
trouve dans l'Hexagone avec un logement
de fait à tenant bâtiment d'exploitation
et exclus du champ de recouvrement de la
SPA et donc il faut qu'on puisse
l'exclure je change recouvrement de la
SPA parce que ça n'est pas tout à fait
comme ça que les choses sont construites
dans les territoires ultramains vous
évoquez en fin de votre questionnaire la
possibilité de développer l'usage de
fonds agricoles afin d'encourager les
transmissions ici aussi qu'on viendrait
de récupérer auprès des notaires le
bilan de l'utilisation du fond agricole
et je suis prêt à examiner la
possibilité d'inclure des beaux ruraux
dans le fond agricole si le besoin est
objective
cela ne fait pas partie des remontées
que j'ai reçu des concertations peloa il
n'empêche que c'est un sujet peut-être
donc vous voudrez parler que vous
voudrez qu'on approfondisse dans les
semaines et les mois qui viennent je me
permets en tout dernier point sur la
question de l'entretien des pistes
forestières désaffectés et des chemins
d'exploitation je l'évoquais il y a
quelques instants Guyane évoqués dans la
concertation pala ce sujet est important
pour pouvoir mobiliser le foncier qui
est disponible
il est important car la pluviométrie
observée sur ce territoire entraîne la
dégradation progressive
des pistes en latérites n'appartient pas
à l'honnêtet d'entretenir des pistes qui
n'ont pas ou plus de vocation forestière
parce que généralement ils ont été créés
pour ça conformément arbitrage
concernant le décroisement des
responsabilités entre l'état des
conseils régionaux dans le cadre de la
gestion de la nouvelle programmation
fait adhère la collectivité territoriale
de Guyane doit en principe disposer de
la pleine responsabilité des
financements des desserts forestières il
me semble que la relation d'État en ce
domaine consistera planifier avec le
concours de l'ONF
les investissements nécessaires sur la
base des accords de financement qui
auront pu être obtenus voilà les
quelques éléments que je voulais vous
donner monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs en ouverture de
cette discussion et je suis à votre
disposition pour répondre à vos
questions
merci monsieur le ministre pour vos
propos liminaires je vais maintenant
laisser la parole au rapporteur du moins
à celle qui est qui est présente
aujourd'hui vivait au pèse et puis je
vous proposerai par la suite connaître
présent de pouvoir interpeller le
ministre pour ceux qui le souhaitent
merci monsieur le Président merci
monsieur le ministre pour vos propos
alors moi je voudrais revenir sur
quelques points vous avez parlé
d'indivision de transmission alors au
cours de nos entretiens il semblerait
que certains agriculteurs ils sont
peut-être pas très très nombreux mais
ils sont quand même bien qu'ils
entretiennent leur terre depuis de
nombreuses années n'en sont pas dans son
toujours pas les propriétaires donc ils
préfèrent faire leurs indivisions par
rapport à leurs enfants leurs
petits-enfants plutôt que de parce que
en fait il n'y a jamais eu d'acte
notarié bon à l'époque où on leur a
laissé les terres les entretenir
donc ne voulant pas se défaire de leur
propriété ce que l'on peut comprendre il
préfère faire des indivisions à leurs
enfants qui nous ont peut-être même pas
agriculteurs donc c'est peut-être un
problème qu'il faudrait déjà résoudre ça
permettrait peut-être à certaines
agriculteurs de pouvoir voilà ça on l'a
quand même entendu quelquefois moi
j'aurais aimé souhaité j'aimerais savoir
comment sera décliné le plan o qui a été
présenté fin mars par le Président de la
République de la République pour
l'agriculture dans les dromes et comment
assurer surtout le financement des
investissements d'entretien pour
l'irrigation les retenues colinaires
parce que bon ben évidemment ça
représente une certaine somme d'argent
est-ce que vous pourriez également nous
préciser le calendrier de la mise en
place du projet de loi d'orientation et
d'avenir agricoles et les dispositions
surtout susceptibles concerner les
outre-mer je crois que des demandes et
des propositions il y avait des
consultations qu'en est-il ressorti je
crois que pour l'instant c'est peut-être
vous avez évoqué le fond agricole pour
l'instant c'est voilà c'est quelques
questions que j'aurais souhaité
avoir des réponses je vous remercie
monsieur le ministre j'en rajoute juste
une et puis je lui laisse le ministre
pouvoir y répondre est-ce que dans le
siome
vous réservez les mesures agricoles
potentielles ultramarines pour rejoindre
la question de Vivette pour la loi que
vous allez préparer ou est-ce qu'il y
aura peut-être des mesures déjà
préalables dans le ciel voilà c'est
juste une question pour avoir un peu de
visibilité vraiment sur pardon cohérence
avec les actions du Sud c'est ça soit le
soit le gouvernement des cycle dans le
cadre du Siam il y a des mesures enfin
l'agriculture ultramarine qui sont
actées par le gouvernement soit
effectivement ces mesures où les athées
directement dans la loi qui viendra
l'automne c'est plus une question de
mode opératoire qu'autre chose de
lisibilité
sur le premier point ça mériterait pour
le coup là je j'aimerais des documenter
même si vous le dites peut-être pas
beaucoup de cas mais c'est kexiste mais
je vois bien la mécanique qui doit
s'opérer pour que celui qui exploite et
qui ne perd pas ce
problème c'est d'ailleurs valable
partout
un territoire national c'est je sais pas
si c'est un cas spécifique très marrant
mais je vois bien la question mais ça ça
mériterait des documenter pour qu'on
puisse regarder ce qu'on peut faire et
si c'est un cas où mais c'est c'est oui
c'était plutôt des questions de nature
orales que des questions de nature
écrites mais ça pour le coup c'est pas
pour ne pas vous répondre ça donne
nécessiterait d'être documenté pour voir
le volume si c'est des cas particuliers
enfin si on s'enlève de la dizaine ou
des dizaines ou ça relève d'un volume
plus important deuxième élément je fais
un paquet global si vous permettez
l'expression sur ploa d'abord calendrier
deux un peu contenu et trois
coordinations avec les autres mesures
calendrier qu'on a il conforme à ce que
ce qui avait été annoncé une
concertation
[Musique]
qui s'est terminée au mois de mai juin
comme prévu un travail de consolidation
de ce qui s'est dit dans la concertation
avec prouve des groupes de travail
nationaux et des groupes de travail
territoriaux y compris ultramarins
l'objectif étant qu'on puisse soumettre
à la délibération du conseil des
ministres début d'automne
en octobre le texte et qui puisse après
naviguer parce que c'est l'expression
dans la navette
parlementaire à l'automne enfin c'est à
l'automne et débordant sur l'automne
vous connaissez largement aussi bien que
moi les procédures vous voyez à peu près
dans quelle horizon à date l'horizon
qu'on a c'est toujours je dis avec
prudence c'est de ne pas que ce soit une
question de volonté mais pour avoir été
ministre des Relations avec le Parlement
ce n'est jamais le mécanique tout à fait
certaine
ça peut parfois changer mais en tout cas
c'est l'objectif c'est l'objectif après
nous le texte doit être prêt et après il
appartiendra au Parlement et
un Matignon de regarder le calendrier
mais on est bien dans ce calendrier là
deuxième élément sur la question donc
qu'est-ce qu'on souhaite avoir comme
bloc dans ces éléments là qu'est-ce qui
ressort de la concertation sont prêtés
définitivement ce qui aura dans le texte
il y a tout un volet de qu'est-ce qu'on
tire comme conséquence de la nécessité
d'atteindre la souveraineté
agricole et alimentaire sont nos
territoires avec sans doute un élément
particulier dans les territoires
ultramarins parce que là on est sur des
contingences qui sont plus fortes et des
contraintes qui sont plus fortes sur ces
territoires là et donc qu'est-ce qu'elle
doit être comment repose le principe de
souveraineté dans les différents textes
assez fondateurs d'ailleurs de la
culture je pense au code rurales en
particulier qu'est-ce que ça comme
conséquence sur les procédures sur les
priorités sur l'accès aux moyens de
production sur l'accès aux foncier
plutôt un principe mais c'est un
principe qui doit s'imposer compris dans
les politiques publiques puisque parfois
en hiérarchie c'est pas la souveraineté
qui vient s'imposer souvent alors je dis
pas qu'il faut qu'elle s'impose surtout
mais il me semble que c'est un élément
important deuxième élément on a tout un
travail à porter sur la question
foncière alors je répète ce que j'ai
souvent dit ce texte n'est pas un texte
foncier vous savez quelque chose au
Sénat parce que vous avez déjà examiné
quelques textes fonciers
je sais toujours comment ça commence je
sais jamais comment ça finit parce que
pardon de l'expression un peu libre mais
sur le foncier au début tout le monde
est d'accord sur les constats à la fin
plus compliqué de se mettre d'accord sur
la manière de résoudre les difficultés
ça s'appelle la politique mais le
foncier est assez éminent dans le
registre comme vous le savez
mais on ne peut pas parler de
transmission d'installation de
transition sans parler de la question
foncière il me semble qu'on a un sujet
question du portage foncier
et de la place que peuvent avoir les
établissements publics fonciers et les
places que peuvent avoir les affaires
dans cet exercice là
on voit bien qu'on a des limites du
portage foncier contenu de ce qu'est la
structuration des affaires et comment on
leur donne les moyens et comment on
incrémente aussi les établissements
publics fonciers qui existent dans tel
ou tel territoire pour faire en sorte ça
c'est un élément et de il y a ce qu'on
appelle ce que j'appelle moi le portage
de capitaux vous avez désormais des
exploitations qui contenus des grands
dérèglements climatiques économiques
géopolitiques font que vous allez voir
votre banquier la fragilité du système
est si grande que
ça vient freiner l'installation et
favorise ça favorise plutôt
l'agrandissement comment on allège cette
partie de portage de capitaux c'est un
élément me semble-t-il qui est très
important troisième volet alors c'est
pas dans l'ordre forcément c'est pour
vous donner un peu ce qui sort c'est la
question de l'orientation de
l'attractivité des métiers
à mon sens c'est dès le plus jeune âge
qui a besoin de retrouver et de
redécouvrir ça fait partie pour moi
d'ailleurs du pacte aussi une partie de
y compris des querelles que nous voyons
fleurir parfois sur les sujets agricoles
elles tiennent à ce que peu de gens sont
désormais en lien
première deuxième voire troisième
génération avec le mot d'accord parce
que 80% des gens vivent dans des
territoires urbains que la culture
urbaine s'est développée partout si je
peux dire et que la connaissance de ce
qui est la réalité agricole les cycles
de vie etc pose problème donc ça c'est
un élément initial de
comment dirais-je de connaissance
de comment ça marche et puis après plus
tard dans le cycle scolaire de comment
on fait découvrir les métiers on a
besoin de réouvrir ce champ là quatrième
élément c'est le champ de la formation à
la fois pour faire évoluer nos modèles
de formation jeudi d'une phrase
lapidaire pour pas être trop longue mais
on raisonnait plutôt
filière il faut qu'on arrive à
construire des systèmes de formation qui
résonne filière et système ce qu'on a
besoin de construire une formation qui
permette à quelqu'un le vrai défi c'est
de construire des parcours de formation
qui permettent à des agriculteurs d'être
adapté ou adaptable ou dérèglement
climatique ou grand bouleversement
personne ne peut dire qu'on installe
quelqu'un aujourd'hui avec un modèle qui
durera 40 ans compte tenu des comptins
du dérèglement climatique et donc on a
besoin de construire un appareil de
formation qui évidemment soit filière
mais qui soit adapté et de on a besoin
de construire quelque chose
qui a commencé mais dans les systèmes de
formation qui puissent travailler sur la
question de la transition climatique de
la transition environnementale moi je ne
pose jamais souveraineté
et transition ce que je pense qu'il n'y
aura pas de souveraineté si on n'est pas
capable de mener des transitions il y a
des territoires aujourd'hui qui sont
sous tel contraintes climatiques pas les
contraintes réglementaires c'est des
contraintes climatiques que si on
n'engage pas les agriculteurs et on
accélère pas on leur donne pas les
capacités d'accélérer cette transition
et de l'agriculture disparaîtra donc on
a besoin de travailler à ça ça pose la
question aussi me semble-t-il de la
formation des formateurs et de tout
l'encadrement agricole parce que c'est
un changement de paradigme comme on dit
c'est les lycée agricoles les champs de
l'agriculture les conseillers divers et
il faut que tout le monde se mette en
ligne pour penser système penser
transition penser le système sous
dérèglement divers en particulier
dérèglement climatique et c'est cet un
élément qui me paraît qui me paraît
important voilà et puis il faut qu'on
réfléchisse à un certain nombre d'outils
on est dans une forme de paradoxe
plus que jamais il y aurait besoin de
coopération et les grandes lois
fondatrices 60 et 62
Edgar Pisani avait posé les principes
des organisations sociétaires des cumin
etc comment continuer à consolider ces
outils et comment dans ces outils ou des
outils qu'il faudrait inventer on fait
en sorte que de nouvelles formes
d'organisation collectives se fassent
oui parfois des systèmes d'assolement en
commun qui existent qui permettent de
travailler ensemble sans être tout à
fait dans un gars oui c'est des systèmes
comme ça qui sont et comment on a fait
puis dernier volet
[Musique]
sur ploua j'essaie de vous donner
quelques pistes aujourd'hui de réflexion
évidemment il y a des questions fiscales
mécanisme d'incitation a des volontaires
mécanismes d'incitation à la session du
foncier voilà c'est tout ça qu'il faudra
aussi décliner évidemment dans cette
dans cette dernière point là-dessus
tout n'est pas dans le texte
heureusement d'ailleurs j'ai pas la
prétention de dire que
vous avez vous avez eu la gentillesse de
dire monsieur le Président je sais pas
ce que ça voulait dire comme acception
une grande loi
on verra plus tard si elle est pas si
c'était la taille que vous viviez ou le
l'important sous l'ambition oui c'est
une loi qui doit être ambitieuse sur un
certain nombre de sujets mais nous avons
par ailleurs des objets qui sont déjà si
je peux me permettre dans l'atmosphère
et qui sont dans le somme d'un point de
vue général je pense à la question de la
planification
c'est planification écologique la
planification carbone c'est pas ça n'a
pas vocation à figurer dans un texte la
planification sur les pestifs pesticide
pardon ça n'a pas vocation à rentrer
dans un texte comme ça donc ça va venir
s'incrémenter
on a par ailleurs évoqué non j'ai pas
évoqué encore le plan souveraineté
fruits et légumes plantes souveraineté
faisait légumes il est déjà posé y
compris dans sa déclinaison ultramarine
ça peut vocation à venir le bouleverser
le texte il viendra et les décisions du
ciel viendront consolider avec le texte
l'important je vais vous dire en ce
moment moi me semble-t-il et c'est la
difficulté qu'on a collectivement c'est
de trouver la cohérence d'ensemble
c'est que la trajectoire carbone soit
conforme au moyen de production et aux
outils qu'on donne aux agriculteurs que
la volonté d'installation sont conformes
aux outils fonciers à la fiscalité qu'on
met en place que la fiscalité qu'on a
sur une fiscalité plutôt incitative à la
transition plutôt qu'autre chose il faut
qu'on arrive à réemboîter ça donc pour
le coup j'ai une grande vigilance moi y
compris vis-à-vis du monde agricole à
essayer et puis les collectivités aussi
elle sait que tout ça est un sens ce
qu'on voit bien un peu le les tableaux
qui se qui sont en train de s'esquisser
mais quand vous cumulez la décarbonation
la biodiversité la question de l'eau et
tout ça vous voyez ne serait-ce que ces
trois sujets parfois il peut y avoir des
frottements et des choses qui sont pas
forcément facile à liner ça va même du
coup c'était pas fait exprès mais du
coup je le déclinaison du plan haut
d'abord on a plutôt très différent dans
les territoires ultramarins que
que dans l'Hexagone
l'idée c'est de travailler un peu de la
même façon ceci est en première élément
il faut qu'on travaille à la sobriété à
l'hectare c'est-à-dire que il faut de
toute façon on a une ressource en eau
qui est plus compliquée à ça veut pas
dire
comment dire ça veut pas dire qu'il
tombe structurellement moins d'eau à
l'année sauf certains territoires il va
tomber moins d'eau
là je pense à l'Hexagone en tout cas en
particulier dans certains territoires
mais les territoires il va tomber autant
d'eau mais il va tomber de l'eau comme
on en a connu encore ce qu'on en connaît
cette année
vous avez des régions qui avaient pas vu
d'autres depuis 8 mois quasiment ou six
mois et qui ont pris 300 mm je pense au
Vaucluse par exemple
depuis un mois et demi donc on a une
héréticité de l'eau donc il faut qu'on
travaille sur cette
arythmie climatique qui s'amplifie deux
avec des phénomènes qui sont
assez ennuyeux c'est qu'on a peu d'eau
on va avoir en plus moins d'eau qui va
s'infiltrer dans les sols et plus d'eau
de caractères un peu torrentiel
et demain dans le Cher
pour voir ce qui s'est passé vous avez
50 mm en 20 minutes et donc c'est
au-delà en terme d'efficacité agricole
elle est quand même beaucoup plus faible
deuxième élément il y a un apport mais
ça c'est plutôt du côté de chez mon
collègue BECHU un travail qui va être
fait pour les collectivités ultramarines
notamment sur l'accès à l'eau pour le
coup l'accès à l'eau potable
troisième élément on est en train de
regarder nous dans France 2030 ce qu'on
peut décliner d'une spécificité sur le
le financement en particulier dans le
plan fruits et légumes d'accès à l'eau
pour avec des systèmes qui soient plus
efficients et plus économe en eau pour
ces territoires donc c'est ça la
déclinaison qui va se faire
progressivement c'est sobriété à
l'hectare si je vais résumer on a besoin
de sobriété parce que c'est plus rare
et dans un alors je pense que je dis que
hexagone je prétends pas connaître dans
le détail ce qui se passe du côté
ultramarin mais cette question au niveau
de l'Hexagone c'est que probablement il
y a plus d'hectares à irriguer mais dans
un volume qui est plus rare ça veut dire
qu'il faut plus de sobriété
c'est valable aussi d'ailleurs sur la
question c'est le travail de recherche
qu'on doit faire sur des variétés plus
résilientes
à l'eau et donc c'est tout le travail de
recherche et d'innovation et c'est pour
ça qu'on pousse au niveau européen
d'ailleurs on appelle les nouvelles
techniques génomiques les MBT ou le NGT
on devrait avoir un texte normalement au
mois de juillet si tout va bien qui nous
permettra quand même d'accéder à des
moyens technologiques qui permettent
d'accélérer le processus qui sont les
processus naturels voilà les éléments
comme ça rapidement que je peux vous
donner sur ces trois questions que vous
vous posez
simplement peut-être faire un petit
rappel sur le sium juste pour savoir si
vous avez l'intention ces gouvernements
l'intention d'avoir des mesures dédiées
à l'agriculture outre-mer ou si on les
réserve effectivement pour ah non non il
y aura des mesures qui seront intégrées
arbitrage c'est pas le sujet c'est
simplement
moi je pense qu'il faut essayer de
mettre dans la loi ce qui relève de la
loi
les politiques publiques ne relèvent pas
de la loi vous voyez ce que je veux dire
c'est donc c'est il me semble que dans
un texte comme celui de loi de celui-là
celui-là pardon le pacte
est une chose la loi c'est ce qui relève
de modifications législatives pas dire
qu'il y a pas du déclaratif comme dans
toute loi et après les politiques
publiques non donc dans le Sion il y
aura bien des mesures intégrées parce
que majoritairement c'est des mesures
qui sont nature non législatives
merci monsieur le ministre je vais
mettre en laisser la parole mes
collègues j'ai une demande de parole de
Marie-Laure feneraors c'est la triste de
Guyane
[Musique]
bonjour
la SAFER vous avez rappelé tout à
l'heure que la SAFER Guyane a eu
beaucoup de mal pour s'installer ça fait
déjà plus de deux ans d'ailleurs et
pourtant cette structure n'est toujours
pas opérationnelle faute d'agrément
c'est agrément devait être délivré par
votre ministère depuis plusieurs mois
outre le fonctionnement l'absence
d'agrément entrave l'accès aux
subventions publiques et ne permet pas à
la Saint affaire de garantir son budget
alors première question monsieur le
ministre quand la SAFER Guyane
obtiendra-t-elle son agrément la
deuxième question concerne le droit de
préhension justement qui permet de
limiter la spéculation foncière et
favoriser le développement local
aussi Monsieur le Ministre pouvons-nous
imaginer une adaptation du droit de
préhension de la SAFER de Guyane car je
rappelle qu'en Guyane il y a une
prédominance de beaux amphytéotique qui
permet souvent à des particuliers de
réaliser des projets privés en ayant
échappé à l'exercice de droit de
préhension et pour terminer vous l'avez
évoqué tout à l'heure lors des Accords
de Guyane
signé le 21 avril 2017 la collectivité
de Guyane et l'État s'était engagée à
fournir les moyens financiers pour le
démarrage de la SAFER Guyane soit
500.000 euros annuel pouvez-vous me dire
quand le ministère de l'Agriculture
respectera son engagement je vous
remercie pour vos réponses monsieur le
ministre
je propose monsieur le ministre de
prendre deux ou trois intervenants et
puis te faire une réponse en bloc sera
peut-être plus simple le prochain
intervenant en Georges passion et
ensuite Dominique théophile
bon je serais très bref puisque
j'avais quasiment les mêmes questions
que que Marie le problème de la SAFER
d'un problème criant qui a soulevé
beaucoup de polémiques
en Guyane parce que ça remonte quand
même aux accords de Guyane en 2017 déjà
la Guyane était avec paillote les deux
seuls territoires français à ne pas voir
de sa faire
dans les accords de Guyane ça a été
signé le président de la République
quand il est venu en 2017
à renouveler l'engagement
là ça fait
pu voir le jour en 2021 et pour des
raisons je crois liées au président qui
avait été choisi il n'y a pas eu
d'agrément donc une safer sans agrément
on sait ce que ça peut être bon en 2023
tout récemment une nouvelle présidente
Haïti désigné et jusqu'à maintenant
toujours pas d'agrément ni pour la SAFER
ni pour la présidente donc pas de
possibilité d'avoir de subventions
publiques sans agrément et comme le
disait Marie-Laure en termes de
cession aussi de fonciers impossibilité
d'intervenir parce que
la Guyane c'est des beaux en phytotique
les terrains appartenant à 90% à l'état
comme l'a dit le président donc
impossibilité également d'opérer parce
qu'il y a pas de d'agrément pas de
possibilité d'adaptation réalité
guyanaise donc avec les bouts en
phytéotique et puis encore bien sûr
l'engagement de l'État qui n'est pas
honoré au niveau des 500.000 euros la
collectivité de Guyane a donné les fonds
à verser sa coup de part mais l'état
jusqu'à maintenant ne verse toujours pas
ça coûte pas
donc
j'insiste après Marie-Laure pour que la
situation de la SAFER soit vue et
qu'elle fonctionne quel est le moyen de
fonctionner parce que bon ils savent
faire une coquille vide ça n'a pas de
sens
et ensuite je serai le ministre pour
répondre
oui bonjour monsieur le ministre vous
savez l'augmentation de la surface
agricole utile aux Antilles et
déterminante pour renforcer la
souveraineté alimentaire des territoires
les jeunes ont du mal à s'installer le
projet indepogée innovant peine à
trouver des parcelles agricoles le
développement des filières et freiné par
ce point de blocage alors quand est-ce
que l'État est-ce que l'État peut
s'engager à faire à posséder à un
inventaire de ces des terrains dont il
est propriétaire pour mettre en place ce
qui est urgent mettre en mettre en
oeuvre des modalités d'évolution de
certaines parcelles aux jeunes
agriculteurs on pourra pas parler et
actionner ce qu'on appelle l'auto
suffisance alimentaire sans parler de la
surface disponible or l'État dans nos
territoires et propriétaire de beaucoup
beaucoup de parcelles il serait
souhaitable et rapide pour anticiper de
faire un point sur l'inventaire et faire
des choix
est-ce que vous l'envisagez et est-ce
que ce sera aussi à l'ordre du jour sur
les discussions concernant le pan sur le
foncier agricole dans le somme
merci beaucoup madame et monsieur le
sénateur sur la question de la Guyane
en fait la vérité je prends en cours de
route ce sujet qui m'a l'air un peu
compliqué
première élément il fallait qu'on trouve
une solution de gouvernance avec la
désignation d'une nouvelle présidente
qui puisse agréer si je peux dire
localement
dans des conditions que je ne vous
décris pas parce que vous connaissez
comment la situation de danse tension
j'ai été sollicitée par la
safarnationale d'ailleurs il va être
procédé à l'agrément de la présidente
dans la semaine première élément ça se
met il faut qu'on remette dans l'ordre
pendant je regarde à deux voix parce que
vous comme vous êtes en visio et en je
fais pas des mouvements de thérapie mais
en premier élément agréer la précédente
deuxième élément elle a vocation une
fois qu'elle est agrée parce que c'est
un peu le chat qui se mord la queue il a
précédé il peut pas y avoir de plans
purée annuels comme people
et pas les moyens qui sont dévolués donc
deuxième élément dès lors qu'elle va
être agréée il lui appartiendra et nous
on est prêt à accompagner et à les aider
dans cette affaire là
c'est ce que c'est ce que j'allais
presque vous dire mais mettez les mots
de la bouche on peut essayer de regarder
pour avoir parce qu'il y a eu du temps
perdu je ne dis pas le contraire là faut
qu'on fasse ça mais il faut qu'on a un
plan plus réel qui permettra par
ailleurs et ensuite de faire en sorte
que le plan pluriel d'activité puisse
permettre d'agréer assez vite parce que
je suis d'accord avec vous ça assez duré
je prends la paume collective il faut
qu'on arrive mais on peut pas agréer la
SAFER tant qu'on n'a pas un programme
pluriannuel donc ça c'est pas le chat
qui se mord la queue c'est juste qu'il
faut qu'on vous appuie qu'on appuie à
safer de Guyane dans sa structuration
qui permettra évidemment ensuite de
regarder comment
comment ça peut se faire d'un point de
vue financier vous l'avez dit Madame
c'est noté c'est la troisième étape
parce qu'il y a des besoins d'activer
les sujets de droit de pension donc
c'est dans cet ordre là que c'est fait
je suis à votre disposition continue
ainsi que mon cabinet
ici présent pour pour que vous me disiez
si ça bloque si vous avez besoin de
soutien complémentaire enfin avec les
équipes qui suivent les outre-mer ici et
ailleurs on est tout à fait à votre
disposition parce que je sais que c'est
un outil dont vous avez besoin il me
semble que c'est un élément important et
donc le le
cet élément là est important deuxième
élément j'ai juste un mot il y avait il
y avait des reliquats ou des éléments de
financement dans le Gym de la précédente
safer qui vont être versées à la SAFER
nouvellement en cours d'agrément mais
c'est pas c'est pas les sommes encore en
jeu mais ça participera de la de
l'équation financière qu'il faut qu'on
essaie de trouver deuxième année donc
voilà pour la partie Guyane
on commence à franchir des étapes c'est
un peu long je vous l'accorde assez
volontiers maintenant qu'on a
manifestement une gouvernance on doit
pouvoir se mettre en endommage pour
aller vite sur la question sur la
question de l'agrément définitif de la
SAFER l'agrément n'ayant qu'un seul
objectif c'est que la SAFER puisse agir
sur son territoire y compris avec les
moyens et moi je me sens engagé comme
tous les autres en tout cas moi
personnellement me s'engager par les
engagements qui avaient été pris à
l'époque sur cette question sur cette
question là donc il y a pas lieu ni à
date maintenant de remettre en cause cet
engagement là me semble-t-il deuxième
élément sur la question globale enfin
plus globale de qui a été posé
par le sénateur sur la question
souveraineté mise à disposition foncière
par l'État
oui la question de la souveraineté ça va
être la question de la mobilisation du
foncier et dans des territoires va
souveraineté sécurité autonomie parce
que on peut parler dans ces territoires
d'un intérêt à avoir de l'autonomie
alimentaire pour des raisons de
d'éloignement et de nécessiter de ne pas
être soumis qui a une inflation qui un
blocus fait par exemple à ce qui s'est
passé sur la covid qui pose des
problèmes assez lourds de dépendance qui
sont à mon avis très mauvais pour tout
le monde et donc moi j'ai donc on a
besoin de ça on a besoin quand même
aussi de penser la diversification parce
que si on veut couvrir les besoins on
voit bien qu'il y a des territoires qui
sont plus spécialisés dans tel ou tel
production il faut qu'on pense et ça
c'est la partie au territoire de s'en
saisir mais quand même l'autonomie c'est
pas l'autonomie sur un produit autonomie
c'est de regarder sur l'ensemble du
besoin le maximum de ce qu'on peut
couvrir alors évidemment on n'a pas du
tout les mêmes situations d'un
territoire à l'autre je ne prétends pas
les connaître mais enfin j'ai une vague
idée de la différence qui peut y avoir
entre les uns ou les autres troisième
élément je suis pas du tout faire fermer
à ce que ce que vous vous reposer là
c'est à dire qu'on essaie de regarder ce
qu'il peut y avoir comme comme foncier
disponible alors j'ai du mal à le
quantifier mais je vais regarder je vais
lui demander ce qu'il soit documenté le
foncier qui état on va dire qui serait
disponible et qui pourrait être mise en
mise à bas une mise en exploitation pour
installer les jeux agriculteurs au fond
c'est presque plus simple quand on est
mal chez soi de décider aussi de ce
qu'on peut faire on est moins sous les
contingences le succession de
propriétaires privés et ça ça me paraît
pas forcément une mauvaise idée donc
c'est celui de l'État c'est un empêche
pas et ça n'obéère pas la nécessité que
nous ayons à travailler on évoqué la
question de la SAFER en Guyane mais
ailleurs que le gros du volume est sans
doute sur le en terme de foncier en
termes de foncier pour installer des
jeunes pour atteindre un objectif
d'autonomie
et de souveraineté alimentaire le gros
du foncier est plutôt dans les mains du
privé mais ils sont que là dans ce des
territoires où le foncier est rare tout
le foncier qu'on peut essayer
d'expertiser comme appartenant à l'État
et deux comme pouvant être utilisé
sous des formats de beaux qu'il faut
imaginer je suis assez d'accord donc je
propose que peut-être on en reparle
entre nous et avec vous ensuite pour et
avec ceux qui voudront au Sénat pour
regarder comment on peut avancer pour
pour regarder ce qu'elle est la part
qu'on peut prendre nous nous état sur
cette sur ce sujet
la parole au Président je reçois un
Rapin
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre vous avez fait une belle
synthèse de tout ce que pouvait
représenter aujourd'hui tout ce qui
était nécessaire pour mettre en place un
modèle
d'agriculture autonome en tout cas
d'auto suffisant s'alimentaire sur des
territoires où on sait que ce n'est pas
facile ça n'est pas facile d'autant qui
manque de foncier c'est rappelé partout
mais que si la volonté d'augmenter les
capacités foncières en outre-mer pour
développer l'agriculture ce qui est tout
à fait louable et noble reste un écueil
par rapport à tout ce que vous avez
décliné autonomie énergétique gestion de
l'eau etc on sait très bien qu'il faudra
des bâtiments
donc aujourd'hui comment on intègre
c'est nécessaire
évolution
pour avoir une agriculture suffisante en
production et en qualité comment on
intègre la difficulté qu'on connaît en
outre-mer de pouvoir avoir des bâtiments
puisqu'on est soumis d'un côté à la loi
littorale et de l'autre côté très
souvent à la loi mentale mais ça c'est
ma première question et deuxièmement
pour avancer dans ce plan on sait très
bien qu'il faudra beaucoup d'argent
on sait très bien aujourd'hui que la
Commission européenne a à l'égard du
modèle agricole français quelques
quelques réticences
est-ce que des fonds FEDER
sont dévolus à l'évolution de ce modèle
je pensais qu'on prenne une série pardon
vous dites FEDER vous dites
en général parce qu'on pourrait avoir
les deux ouais mais c'est pour ça que je
vous interroge
c'est naturel mais fédère c'est moins
naturel et c'est en lien avec ma
question sur la vision de la commission
sur le modèle agricole français ou alors
je sais mais c'est pas pour cultiver un
échange entre vous et moi mais je suis
pas sûr qu'on puisse dire que la
Commission est un problème avec le
modèle agricole français
je pense qu'il y a des débats à la
Commission sur la manière de financer
l'agriculture mais pas que l'agriculture
française il y a ceux en gros qui disent
c'est une activité de souveraineté il
faut qu'on revienne à ce qui était
les fondements de la politique agricole
commune c'était quoi c'était produit en
quantité en qualité et à des prix
raisonnables à nous concitoyens qui
sortaient de d'un conflit mondial qui
avait fait quand même qu'on était il y a
70 ans faut jamais oublier ça pas tout à
fait en capacité de nourrir nos
populations
et donc ils disent c'est les aides
couplées c'est
primauté à l'économie etc puis ceux qui
sont en train d'évoluer par ailleurs et
c'est là que c'est peut-être le modèle
que vous évoquez qui disent oui mais
l'agriculture doit rendre des services
d'une autre nature écosystème et
environnementaux
qui est très
jusqu'à nouvel ordre je n'ai pas vu que
le premier fondement a été remis en
cause y compris par la personne que vous
venez
puis à ce qui se passe la nouvelle
Pâques qui se met en place là en 2023
elle ne fait pas défaut à ce qui a été
la pacte depuis sa création depuis 62
il y a des évolutions parce qu'il faut
qu'on tienne en compte sans doute ce qui
est de ce qu'on j'aime pas trop
l'expression des attentes de la société
est-ce que la société n'est pas une
comme le consommateur je sais pas ce que
c'est que le consommateur moi il y a des
consommateurs la demande est parfois
paradoxale et nous sommes nous-mêmes
paradoxaux le sujet qui va y avoir
devant nous à un moment c'est
il y a la le modèle financier qui permet
de financer l'agriculture et puis il y a
le modèle financier qui va qui permettre
de financer les autres services de
l'agriculture et moi je pense que le
débat qu'on doit avoir au niveau
européen c'est la finance carbone ça
marche comment pour l'agriculture parce
qu'une grande partie de la solution
c'est dans le stockage carbone d'un
point de vue agricole même chose sur la
question forestière d'ailleurs au
passage et donc ça ça peut pas être
financé par la PAC
parce qu'au fond des carbone pour les
autres quand vous faites du Biomat
matériau quand vous faites du
biocarburant par exemple j'étais dans
cette même salle sur la question des
biocarbes pour l'aéronautique en fait
vous financez le décarbonation de
l'aéronautique
donc c'est pas à la Pâque
qui est une politique agricole sur le
sujet de la souveraineté qui est de
financer ça et puis troisième élément
pour pas être trop long il faut que ce
qui est important c'est de se dire quand
même et j'essaie de regarder sur vos
affaires mais de bâtiments troisième
sujet on peut pas on peut pas on peut
plus penser la PAC comme un objet
autonome du monde au sens 1 si on a des
règles contraignantes comment on les
fait appliqués dans les accords
commerciaux
il y a pas de problème avec des règles
contraignantes enfin c'est un vieux
débat enfin vous connaissez ça beaucoup
mieux que moi enfin vous en avez déjà
beaucoup débattu
et deuxième élément je considère que
l'alimentation est une arme
et qu'on ça devrait être une arme de
paix ça peut être une arme de
destruction massive
suffit de voir ce que fait monsieur
Poutine
et donc si l'Europe ne reprend pas
conscience que la politique agricole
c'est pas seulement de se nourrir c'est
déjà de se nourrir deux de pas dépendre
des autres sur les engrais sur l'énergie
parce que sinon vous avez des prix qui
font comme ça
3 c'est canaux frontières
extra-européenne des gens soient quand
même suffisamment pourvu en alimentation
pour pas se retrouver avec des crises
majeures parce que c'est pas chez
Poutine qui aura le problème si on a un
problème d'alimentation
des populations de l'autre rive de la
Méditerranée ou des populations un peu
plus à l'est vous voyez ce que je veux
dire et donc c'est ça qu'il faut poser
dans l'impact donc je répondais juste à
la question de l'Europe n'aime pas le
modèle agricole non le débat la
commission c'est le vieux débat de la
PAC coûte trop cher à quoi ça sert et on
soutient un modèle agricole qu'on veut
pas et donc mais jusqu'à nouvel ordre
mais moi je pense qu'il faut qu'on
combine les deux mais s'il y a des
services environnementaux s'il y a des
services carbone s'il y a des services
biodiversité ça peut pas être la que la
pâte qui paye parce que si ça rend
service à tous
il me semble qu'il faut aller chercher
quelque chose ailleurs je n'oublie pas
qu'on a que le Président de la
République c'est beaucoup battu pour
qu'il y a une taxe carbone aux
frontières
la dévolution la taxe carbone est quand
même pas est complètement inintéressant
il me semble que
il me semble qu'il faut pas les cartes
alors sur la question du bâti
alors je reviens sur FEDER pardon FEDER
offert c'est le truc classique FEDER il
me semble que sur le sujet agricole et
peut-être agricole et transformation oui
peut-être à regarder comment le FEDER
pour revenir intervenir sur le sujet de
l'eau le fait d'air pour intervenir il
peut intervenir à date sur un certain
nombre de sujets donc c'est peut-être là
qu'il faut chercher les choses et les
voix
j'ai du mal à déterminer pour être très
honnête avec vous ce qui est la vision
en revanche de la commission sur les
territoires ultramarins d'abord nous
sommes peu de pays avec des territoires
ultramars
et je reconnais donc ça fait écho
peut-être ce que vous ai dit je
ne sens pas qu'il sache c'est pas un
reproche qui sache parler des
territoires ultramarins en dehors des
fonds qui sont dévolus au territoire
mais je ne sens pas une stratégie y
compris une stratégie de puissance
vis-à-vis de pays comme les nôtres qui
ont quand même des territoires sur les
océans quoi vous voyez ce que qui
pourrait avoir un rôle sur la partie
agricole mais évidemment sur bien
d'autres sujets il me semble que c'est
un point important
sur les constructions oui il y a sans
doute on en a parlé quand la Première
ministre est venue à la Réunion il y a
sans doute un besoin de travailler à des
adaptations qui tiennent compte la
Réunion c'est assez frappant quand vous
cumulez la loi littorale
la loi montagne
bah il vous reste quand même
et le parc et le parc que j'ai vu que
dans lequel nous étions bah là en fait
bon c'est le débat que nous avons dans
[Musique]
et on a vu à quel point la loi littorale
a quand même permis de préserver un
certain nombre de littoraux français
le phénomène qui était comment dire
moi je veux pas les qualifier mais on va
dire un peu spéculer spéculatif ou
excessif donc c'est plutôt par
l'adaptation c'est plutôt la piste sur
laquelle travail la question il me
semble que la contrainte et c'est ce qui
a exprimer la première ministre elle est
ils sont en train d'y travailler du côté
de des services de la première ministre
de Matignon et du ministère des
Outre-mer avec mon collègue car un coup
c'est on essaie de regarder comment on
peut se glisser dans plutôt de la
différenciation territoriale justifiée
sur motif
de contraintes
diverses et variées voilà c'est plutôt
comme ça qu'il faut le faire si on
rentre dans une loi comme ça on y
arrivera pas
si on rentrait d'ailleurs si vous n'avez
pas dit ça si on rentrait dans un
mécanisme législatif on y arrivera pas
me faire on a un troisième sujet si je
comprends bien dans un certain nombre de
territoires ultrama sur les questions
des habitations c'est que les
habitations sont pas forcément à
l'endroit
où se situent l'exploitation
qui est un cas par rapport à l'Hexagone
l'Hexagone on avait plutôt le siège
d'exploitation les terres autour alors
après et les agrandissements c'est plus
tout à fait là je me décris un modèle il
y a 80 ans
c'est pas tout à fait le modèle qu'on a
dans les territoires donc la décoration
du lieu d'habitation
du lieu de du lieu d'exploitation pour
une un sujet parce qu'on peut pas dire
comme on fait aujourd'hui dans
l'Hexagone c'est-à-dire que le siège
d'exploitation est une artificialisation
particulière puisqu'elle est liée à une
activité agricole donc là quand
l'exploit l'habitation est à 12 km et
donc il va falloir qu'on travaille sur
cette question là
voilà qu'on travaille sur cette question
là parce que s'il y a trop de déliaisons
entre le territoire d'exploitation et le
territoire d'habitation comment on
arrive quand même axe de constitue pas
un frein pour l'installation
merci trois prises de parole Georges
passion Michel Jacques puis Viviane
Mallet
j'ai cru qu'il y avait pas d'autres
questions et comme on nous a dit qu'il y
avait une plage d'une heure et demie oui
c'est pour avoir un petit peu de
précision toujours sur la SAFER de
Guyane vous avez bien dit que la
présidente allait recevoir son agrément
cette semaine c'est ça bon là ça fait il
faut attendre le programme d'activité
donc dans le cas où ce programme est
fait est-ce que vous pensez que la SAFER
pourrait avoir son agrément avant
septembre prochain
c'est un peu court je pense je pense que
c'est un peu court parce que là on est
quand même le 20 juin
le programme le programme d'activité il
me semble que c'est un il sent que c'est
comme dans une instruction accélérée
c'est pas possible c'est que je ne l'ai
pas aujourd'hui le plan donc j'ai besoin
d'avoir
des éléments sur le plan à finaliser si
c'était qu'on avait le plan et qu'il
fallait
comment dirais-je et qu'il fallait juste
valider là j'entendrai votre
argumentation du mois de septembre mais
aujourd'hui j'ai pas ça sous les yeux
mais pour la raison que vous venez
d'évoquer parce que la présidente elle a
pas elle a été assez récemment nommée
oui oui
faut pas lui demander de faire le plan
avant d'avoir été agréé donc elle est
agréée il sent que c'est un élément donc
le plan est prévu
ce qu'on me donne les éléments de
calendrier c'est un peu ce que j'avais
en tête
l'idée c'est que la présidente installée
elle puisse présenter son plan en
septembre-octobre
si on se donne la même temporalité au
gros ça fait écho est-ce que vous dites
vous dites deux trois mois ça veut dire
fin d'année pour l'agrément
sans que ça ressemble à ça en calendrier
raisonnable
c'est le critère essentiel principal
ouais ouais
il faut qu'on arrive à avoir
ça veut dire c'est
juillet août septembre pour avoir un
plan mais on est prêt à les accompagner
à les aider nous s'il y a des besoins
pour travailler avec l'équipe qui se met
en place que je sais ce que c'est qu'une
équipe qui se met en place bon
que puis ça a été un peu tumultueux
parce que cette affaire là donc faut que
ça s'appelle il faut que ça bosse donc
les deux à la fois en même temps c'est
quand même un peu compliqué mais si on
est sur quelque chose qui est en octobre
ça fait du décembre début janvier sur la
sur la fin qui est posé sur la table du
ministère en septembre c'est tenable de
faire le même sujet que vous disiez
comme si le dossier était là oui je vous
dirais septembre on l'aura pas avant
septembre octobre donc je vous dis
plutôt cet horizon là
pour le coup j'ai été encore plus précis
vous avez raison de me poser la question
sachant que oui
qui peuvent qui peut les encadrer
d'abord la FNSE à faire parce que je
pense qu'ils sont intéressés
et le président national que j'ai eu
recruteur qui a trois jours m'a l'air
temps sur la situation de la présidente
l'agrément de la présidente plus
l'agrément de la SAFER et puis de chez
nous on a on a la DGP
ils sont assez rompus à l'exercice et
ils peuvent
mais on va les voir et on va leur dire
enfin les a vu on va leur redire
vraiment nous on a tout intérêt vraiment
le ministre encore plus
on a tout intérêt à ce qu'on fait à
segrément le plus vite possible parce
que ce privé de cet outil là dans ce
territoire où c'est un petit enjeu quand
même quand je dis petit c'est pour faire
vous voyez c'est ennuyeux pour nous
merci Micheline et vision de Mallet si
Georges pouvait juste éteindre son micro
merci merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
je souhaiterais rebondir sur l'exemple
que vous avez pris tout à l'heure sur la
taxe sur le l'avion et la production de
biocarbures les passagers ultramarins
payent une taxe carburant qui est
reversé au développement du chemin de
fer or comme tout le monde le sait les
territoires électrabarins ne bénéficient
pas le chemin de fer seriez-vous
favorable justement à utiliser cette
taxe pour développer ne serait-ce que
l'agriculture dans le territoire
ultramarin
alors il m'arrive d'être audacieux mais
quand même pas de m'occuper des sujets
qui sont pas les miens parce que là vous
venez me vous voulez que je sois ami
avec Bruno Le Maire et Clément baume à
la fois donc j'ai pas d'avis sur la
question
faut se méfier de la taxe affectée aussi
c'est l'intuition générale de pourtant
je suis on dit toujours que Bercy est
très hostile à la taxe affectée pour des
raisons qu'on connaît bien parce que ça
leur contingente le budget
je suis plus n'étant pas de cette maison
là je suis pas tout à fait le même
sentiment mais
que ça soit tout complètement affecté
c'est quand même un problème mais je
rentre pas dans le détail du projet sur
une pente que je ne saurais utiliser
sans prendre le risque de glisser
rapidement j'ai un sujet un que je
connais pas et de m'appartient pas mais
c'est plus compliqué que ça la vérité
pour ceux qui viennent
je répète je reconnais pas le sujet mais
comme vous comme vous m'y forcez non je
plaisante j'essaie d'y répondre
que une partie alors en général je parle
pas des territoires une partie des taxes
qui sont utilisées pour l'aviation par
des gens qui font du tourisme puis cette
affecté à quelque chose qui est autre
comme moyen de transport ce n'est pas
forcément choquant la question c'est la
part et la question c'est ce vous
territoire ultramment parce que pour le
coup je reconnais que vous êtes un peu
exemple du sujet ferroviaire oui ok mais
je sais pas si c'est une collègue énorme
en plus je suis pas sûr que ça serait je
suis pas sûr que ça serait une collecte
énorme voilà
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre je vais revenir sur la question
qui fâche la CdP vous avez parlé tout à
l'heure donc à la Réunion je parle pas
mon territoire la Réunion deux écoles la
Chambre d'Agriculture avis conforme la
l'Association des Maires demande un avis
simple ça fait très bien alors il faut
t-il réformer
la composition faut-il faire des
réunions
en amont pour que les décisions soient
peut-être mieux comprises et que les
acteurs puissent présenter leur projet
territoriaux et peut-être s'entendre et
notamment j'ai vu qu'à la réunion un
agriculteur interdit de construction
d'un hangar vous avez parlé tout à
l'heure aussi d'habitation et
d'exploitation donc la CdP 90
défavorable pour un hangar et le
tribunal administratif a annulé la
semaine dernière il y a quelques
semaines c'est interdiction
et à demander au père de signer le
permis de construire donc tous les
merdes elles sont en train de se dire
mais ça va faire juste prudence merci
monsieur le ministre pour votre réponse
mais vous avez d'abord bien décrit la
situation c'est un c'est un débat entre
le monde agricole et monde des
collectivités
j'ai perçu ça quand j'étais quand nous
étions à la réunion avec la première
ministre
ça a été évoqué
le président de la République en avait
parlé alors je vais vous dire ce que le
fond de la pensée de ce que je perçois
parce que je en arrivant à la Réunion je
me suis dit c'est un sujet absolument
épidermique et puis dans le débat alors
peut-être parce qu'il y avait la
première ministre et que tout le monde
est comment dire j'ai turbain et donc
restez poli j'ai senti moins de tension
que ça peut-être un peu plus du côté du
monde agricole
et donc je sais pas comment dire il me
semble que c'est un sujet
sur lequel je moi je suis plutôt
favorable je donne mon sentiment comme
ministre de la Culture je pense que le
faire qu'un avis simple c'est très
complexe
parce que
parce que c'est quand même un outil de
régulation et pareil on va voir arriver
d'autres sujets vous voyez ce qu'on a
fait sur
au niveau national sur la question
hexagonale sur la question la question
du voltaïsme on a plutôt été vers une
tendance à dire il faut des avis un peu
pas si simple seulement parce que
parce que sinon on va tirer à Elia et on
est déjà sur je vous laisserai peut-être
mais on est déjà sur la question du
foncier agricole on est déjà sur la
question de la construction sur les
zones agricoles et on va voir arriver en
plus des projets peut-être moins en
Ultra marin mais quand même au-delà de
la pression qu'on connaît sur les
questions touristiques c'est les projets
autour de les énergies renouvelables
parce que c'est pas des territoires qui
et donc on laisse s'échapper tout ça
sans un avis confort moi je pense que ce
serait une erreur alors après on a deux
sujets à mon avis mais intuitivement le
premier jeu partage votre sentiment que
ça peut pas être une décision qui donne
le sentiment de tomber comme ça sans
qu'on a eu le temps de s'en expliquer de
s'en expliquer et de présenter son
projet et que la cdp9 ne soit pas juste
sur j'applique strictement et ça tombe
il y a des projets qui justifient qui
puissent avoir un avis favorable et
d'autres qui justifient l'inverse donc
je sens qu'il y a un problème de cette
nature là c'est à dire un problème de de
dialogue parce qu'en fait ça a été
tellement une opposition entre le monde
agricole et le monde des collectivités
que le monde agricole dans la cdpaf a
appliqué la règle et sans qu'il y ait un
sentiment un de pouvoir en parler avant
de préparer la décision d'expliciter la
décision troisièmement d'avoir du
recours un petit peu puisque l'affaire
que vous évoquez que je ne connais pas
mais l'affaire ça finit au tribunal non
non mais ça finit au tribunal mais pour
y avoir des voix et moyen de recours
d'appel je pense qu'on aurait besoin de
travailler sur des modalités plutôt qui
permettraient de favoriser le dialogue
et pas de revenir sur la position
initiale qui a une position de blocage
avis simple ou pas avis simple moi je
pense qu'il faut vaut mieux préserver la
question de la vie conforme sinon je ne
sais pas comment c'est des territoires
qui sont sur une pression foncière qui
est terrible beaucoup plus qu'ailleurs
on n'a pas les mêmes preuves dans mon
département du Loir-et-Cher on n'a pas
le même sujet mais encore que sur
l'agrivoltase si on fait pas des avis un
peu solide on va se retrouver avec du de
l'agricole
parfois de façade
on passe raconter l'histoire j'ai pas
complètement aveugle ou des projets
alibi on met de moutons sous 150
hectares de
panneaux photovoltés qu'on dit c'est une
activité agricole c'est relativement une
activité agricole et donc pour faire
écho à ça là c'est la question mais ça
c'est un sujet national mais c'est les
mêmes sujets parce qu'en fait si vous
avez pas des avis qui sont pas seulement
des avis simples moi je pense que vous
avez un problème après je pense que
c'est une question il faut que le
que le monde agricole accepte le
dialogue avec les collectivités
territoriales pour pour justifier parce
que de toute façon d'ailleurs votre
exemple est assez illustratif le monde
agricole lui-même a besoin
bah oui dans le cas que vous évoquez
c'est un dossier agricole qui a été
refusé par la cdp-9 dont manifestement
avait besoin d'agriculteurs et sur
lequel la justice a tranchée voilà donc
ça peut pas être non plus ça revient ce
que je disais tout à l'heure sur la mise
sous cloche ou pas ça peut pas être la
mise sous clochement parce que ces
territoires ont besoin de se développer
comme les autres si on est dans une
position tour restrictive on a on a un
petit sujet et je partage assez ce qui a
été dit par plusieurs d'entre vous on a
des terres qui sont mobilisables encore
et qui sont non exploités parce que je
trouve que il y a un certain nombre de
sujets qui ont pris en termes de
souveraineté dans les territoires
ultramarins où nous avons besoin de
produire et d'assumer la souveraineté
l'autonomie la sécurité qui aujourd'hui
ne sont pas mis en valeur
je comprends tout à fait cette position
là effectivement mais en fait c'est les
mères qui construisent les dossiers les
dossiers sont quand même instruits en
mairie déposés en mairie et après la
décision leur échappe c'est un petit peu
sage je pense que il faudrait qu'il y
ait justement comme on disait tout à
l'heure qui est
une discussion en amont que les projets
soient connus et surtout aussi pour pour
les petites exploitations
soit inhabitation sur souvent on se
retrouve avec sur une quatre voies avec
des tracteurs
c'est pas normal parce que c'est pas
normal que quatre acteurs
qu'un agriculteur ne puisse pas habiter
sur son exploitation et qui se déplace
en tracteur pour aller 10-12 km plus
loin c'est donc je pense qu'il y a des
il y a quelque chose à faire et il faut
qu'on arrive à comprendre aussi les élus
locaux
permettre à ajouter quelque chose je
pense que pour sécuriser tout ça je
pense la même chose d'ailleurs sur la
grivevoltase pendant des mois
je pense qu'on aurait besoin d'une
planification d'une certaine façon c'est
à dire que acteur élu locaux acteurs du
territoire agriculteur se mettent
d'accord sur ce qui est consommable la
trajectoire vous voyez ce que je veux
dire c'est comme ça qu'on va des
passionnés le débat qu'on soit pas
seulement pardon de l'expression au fil
de l'eau c'est pas dossier par dossier
le seul sujet c'est quelle stratégie on
a
sur la question du logement sur la
question du tourisme sur la question des
activités artisanales commerciales ou
industrielle et à partir de là de cette
circulation des P9 ne peut pas être
seulement le lieu de je préserve le
foncier
même si c'est sa vocation
mais c'est
que les stratégie globale partagée avec
les élus parce que là du coup on peut
faire de la planification de en disant
bah ça c'est prioritaire plutôt dans les
projets donc si la cdp9 a se prononcer
vous voyez ce que je veux dire c'est
plutôt comme ça que j'essaierai de
construire un chemin sur cette affaire
là je pense que la planification c'est
nature a rassuré tout le monde y compris
le monde agricole qui peut avoir la
crainte que le l'espace agricole se soit
entre guillemets dévoré
merci Monsieur le Ministre ces
précisions et puis j'ai envie de
rappeler pour pour faire écho à ce que
vous venez de dire sur la planification
et sur la vision holistique que vous
décriviez sur le projet de loi qui est
en préparation ce qui est la difficulté
aujourd'hui c'est le fonctionnement en
silo et effectivement une vision
stratégique qui traite de toutes les
entrées au dossier évidemment que c'est
complexe c'est ce qui rend l'exercice
compliqué mais c'est un exercice
indispensable si on veut avoir une
vision la plus transversale possible
aujourd'hui ce qui manque quand même
relativement je discuter hier avec le
directeur de l'audium que j'ai croisé
web des territoires qui organisé une
séquence sur l'adaptation au changement
climatique en outre-mer innové pour
s'adapter il me disait effectivement
qu'on avait par le passé des feuilles de
route stratégiques en outre-mer sur
chacun des territoires et que ça
permettait d'avoir une vision peut-être
partagée entre tous les acteurs surtout
les champs qui sont couverts et pas
seulement le simple champ entre
guillemets agricole quand on pense que
c'est seulement agricole ça a forcément
des répercussions en termes
d'aménagement du territoire en termes de
formation c'est ce que vous expliquer
tout à l'heure en de filière donc je
pense que cette vision là elle est
extrêmement vertueuse elle est complexe
mais c'est la seule de mon point de vue
aujourd'hui qui permettra comme vous le
dites de dépassionner et de décrisper et
d'éviter justement qu'on découvre sur
des dossiers des points de crispation
qu'on n'avait pas identifié parce qu'on
imaginait qu'il ne relevait pas
forcément du dossier qui est encore
instruction
des moments de planification écologiques
et donc je participe à la planification
phytosanitaire à la planification sur
l'eau à la planification sur la forêt à
la planification sur la biomasse à la
ponification sur l'énergie à la
planification sur la biodiversité
bientôt donc je
dis d'un ton madame mais au début ça
fait un bon
de partout notre affaire mais le jour
j'étais assez frappé on a fait une
réunion de restitution à date des
travaux devant le monde agricole et les
organisations non gouvernementales
protection de l'environnement ils
étaient assez contents qu'on pose un
débat global
j'ai besoin de produire plus de biomasse
plus de biomasse et plus de
photosynthèse plus de photosynthèse
c'est des facteurs de production des
intrants et de l'eau évidemment des
sommes bien de 30 millions de tonnes de
plus de biomasse
donc parce que ça c'est trajectoire
carbone dont j'ai besoin mais
trajectoire carbone dont j'ai besoin si
je ne réponds pas à la question du défi
au du Défi des moyens de production
quelle trajectoire de pesticides qui
soit tenable pour continuer à produire
tout en réduisant
quels sont les contraintes que
j'incrément par ailleurs parce que j'ai
besoin de restaurer quelques systèmes
écologiques donc je rajoute la haie dans
mon affaire puis après oui je trouve que
vous avez raison un ça dépassionne de sa
rassure parce que c'est pas le sentiment
que en permanence on va rajouter quelque
chose qu'on n'a pas vu arriver
alors il y a un petit bémol là dedans je
dis quand un passage c'est le l'élément
perturbateur peut être un perturbateur
au bon ou mauvais sens du terme c'est
qu'il y a des calendriers qu'on maîtrise
et les calendriers nationaux les
calendriers qu'on maîtrise moi c'est le
calendrier européen
dire que j'essaie de tenir une
trajectoire sur l'élevage réduction
réduction de la démission de carbone
corrélation consommation production
[Musique]
et si j'ai un texte bien-être animal qui
arrive par dessus pauvre ça me revient
oui la question n'est pas jugée du texte
c'est juste que si au moment de ma
trajectoire j'arrive avec un texte
supplémentaire à ce moment-là et je
pense que le monde agricole pour le coup
il est très en demande d'un truc global
et qu'on ait une trajectoire qui se
tient depuis un dernier élément que vous
avez évoqué les uns et les autres la
trajectoire se paye
il faut des moyens une trajectoire soit
moyen c'est c'est plus une trajectoire
c'est un objectif c'est un rêve c'est
une utopie c'est bien on est tous un peu
utopique mais à moins c'est pas
illégitime que les gens disent c'est on
est d'accord mais maintenant il va
falloir aligner
il va falloir aligner les moyens pour le
faire mais moi je pense que dans le
monde y compris pour embarquer les gens
et pas mettre les gens en situation de
rupture comme on le voit dans beaucoup
d'endroits sur beaucoup de sujets
si on arrive à décrire ce qui est pas
simple parce que pour avoir participé à
toutes les réunions on finit par perdre
un peu le fil vous avez les bases de
biomasse et les tous les carburants
qu'il faut utiliser pour tous les usages
vous dites à la fin je sais pas si on
n'a pas vendu trois fois la même
biomasse
donc il faut bien réincrémenter parce
que ça va être des débats devant nous si
cette affaire mais je pense que si on va
embarquer les gens et qui ne le vivent
pas comme une contrainte et le stress
permanent de la règle qui change et
d'une planification chaotique je pense
que cet exercice de planification que
nous ont sous l'autorité de la première
année est utile aussi pour ça ça permet
de voir globalement les enjeux et de
dire qu'est-ce que je bouge et quand je
bouge si je dis
il y a tel facteur sur lequel je mets
tel pression comment ça fait bouger tous
les autres si on dit par exemple les
biocarburants ils sont plutôt
réservés pour telle et tel type de
transport comment on aurait organise les
autres vous voyez si EDF me dit je peux
produire ça et parce que c'est tout ça
qui est en boucle dans notre affaire
notre trajectoire carbone et donc je
fais quoi ce que vous dites pardon de
faire cette digression
d'avoir repris la parole derrière vous
mais il me semble que c'est c'est de
nature à rassurer c'est de nature aussi
à construire des filières y compris des
filières de production agricole si j'ai
pas de trajectoire et pas de
planification à la vérité ça on n'y
arrivera pas et le territoire est très
marin ils ont des sujets de
phytosanitaires d'impasse d'usage
orphelins de molécules ils ont c'est
tout ça sur lequel il faut qu'on
travaille
merci Monsieur le Ministre c'était le
mot de la fin finalement donc merci de
votre disponibilité de la qualité de cet
échange je pense que avant tout aussi
pas mal d'éléments de réponse ce soir
merci encore et bonne fin de journée